الجماهير الفلسطينيه تركت المدرج
ونزلت الى ارضيه الملعب كما ذكرت من اجل 3
نوعا ما يعني
بشكل طبيعي هذا هو الاحتلال وهذا هي
فلسطين وهذا ما نوع ما نعيشه اللاعب
الفلسطيني طمني عن وضع زملائك اللاعبين
جوه الغرفه كيف كان الوضع يعني كابتن جميع
اللاعبين احنا تلقينا بعد انتهى الشوط
الاول تلقينا مثيل جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من هذه العنجهيه الاسرائيليه
التي لا تتوقف ابدا الرياضه الفلسطينيه
الان تحت مرمى النيران بكل تاكيد النيران
الاسرائيليه جيبات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
حوطت الساده الشهيد فيصل الحسيني واطلقت
قنابل الغاز المسيله الدموع والان نحن كما
نشاهد يعني
الجماهير الفلسطينيه تركت المدرج
ونزلت الى ارضيه الملعب كما ذكرت من اجل
تلافي نوعا ما يعني ياسر عرفات هذه
المباراه الكبيره التي تكون مغلفه بالصيني
نهائي كاس الشهيد ياسر عرفات
[تصفيق]